finally a rated PG movie that will scare
the living [ __ ] out of kids ParaNorman
so ParaNorman is the story of this kid
he's gonna have a weird kid in school he
gets picked on he sees dead people
hey he's Haley Joel Osment only his
name's Norman long story short there was
a curse that happened some hundreds of
years ago now the dead are rising from
the grave this Norman kid doesn't seem
to have you know left 4 dead 2 so he's
not really equipped to handle this
situation but he has to save the day so
pair of Norman's one of these claymation
type animation movies it has that
old-school Tim Burton ish style and
visually it looks really cool there were
some really cool effects in this movie
some cool cloud movements going on good
depth of field to the 3d I thought
looked really good so I'm gonna be
completely honest with you about this
movie at first I was like this movie's
really slow I understand the movie has
to build up the plot but I think 15
minutes went by it seemed like 45 I was
like come on dude pick up something
happen I know something's gonna happen I
see these flashes of dead people which
is really interesting but let's do it
whatever it may be then it happens and
you're like okay the movies kind of you
know picking up now and when the movies
going you have good characters and two
pretty good jokes at that point though
you're like this is not made for kids
visually there are some frightening ass
scenes in this movie I think this
movie's actually made for teenagers not
quite adults although the adults will be
entertained in this movie definitely not
for kids cuz they're gonna piss their
pants teenagers will get the jokes enjoy
the movie I think it's made for them I
like the characters in this movie it's
like everyone was in Paris Norman's
sister was paired up with this
knucklehead they had their thing going
on
Norman's little fat friend he was funny
and cool he reminded me of that kid from
the big green I don't know if you
remember him yeah totally who that kid
reminded me of in either case they had
some funny stuff going on I liked that
mclovin plays the bully in this movie
would [ __ ] go figure that they're like
all right actor who plays McLovin whose
name Jeremy can't even think of right
now although he's gonna talk in the
third person while he explains it which
is strange people know your face you're
not a bully but you can play a bully by
voice you know yeah you're a voice actor
bully that's fine and he worked for this
movie too now among all these things
that work the thing that didn't work for
me was the pacing in the movie the
movies interesting as hell if for
nothing else I'm just intrigued by the
story and the visuals and everything
that's going on the thing that Norman
to do and that was all awesome and cool
but in watching the road of the movie
how its portrayed in the pacing I was
like let me guess this is a first time
director actually it's directed by two
guys one has a couple movies under his
belt Tale of Despereaux is one of them
but the other guy yeah total first time
director and I think it shows in this
movie they're young directors they
haven't perfected their craft yet so
yeah some of the pacing yeah but then
other scenes will happen where it's not
good it's great you're just watching it
you're like things are coming together I
like the dialogue I like the principle I
like the premise I like the visuals I
like the characters in the end I'm gonna
give the movie props this is movie for
everybody no not at all it's not a very
fast-moving movie it's more of a
character driven movie it's just really
rare in an animation but it's an
animation that's not made for kids it's
made for teenagers and older teenagers I
think that's a misconception don't take
your five-year-old to this movie unless
you want him to sleep in your bed
parents every night for about three
months but with really solid character
is good situations good comedic moments
great visuals and a really good premise
that I really dug when I walked out of
the movie after seeing the entire thing
and processing it all you know you're
putting everything together I was just
like there's something about that movie
that I really loved it surprised me by
being deeper than just your average
animation that's good for families I
will say ParaNorman is a good time no
alcohol required if it didn't have some
of those pacing issues that I'm bitching
about so much in this review this movie
would have at least gotten byte on
blu-ray it's like a nice shirt you know
where it's like that's a nice shirt but
if you ironed it it'd be better so what
is the movie or thing that scared the
living [ __ ] out of you as a kid for me
I'll be honest with you Rudolph the
red-nosed reindeer
the bumble dude freaked me out so
whatever you think might be a little
embarrassing trust me is not more
ludicrous than that whatever it may be
comment below let me know and as always
if you'd like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you